[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the border crisis proved to be a top of
voter issue in a texas special election
myra flores successfully flipped a house
seat red for the first time in almost a
decade in south texas and some analysts
say this could be the start of a red
wave this fall flores was officially
sworn in on tuesday and she joins us
live now
welcome to you thank you very much for
joining us here
thank you so much for having me so what
do you believe
your win means for the republican party
in november
well it means honestly everything
in south texas we have been taken for
granted for a long time and we showed
the democrat party that they do not own
our vote that they have to get to work
and the republican party has invested in
south texas and that's why we were able
to you know spread the message across
our district that we are pro-god
pro-life pro-family all about hard work
we are really the party that is fighting
for the everyday american and i'm just
so proud to be the first republican
congresswoman that was born in mexico
and being a voice for all
hispanics not only in texas district 34
but throughout the country as well you
know you come from a family of
democratic voters i believe you yourself
voted for president obama back in 2008.
and when you take a look at recent uh
polling on president biden's approval
rating with latino voters this latest
quinnipiac poll shows that he is at dire
straits here just 24
support among hispanics
is is the democratic party leaving you
or are you leaving the democratic party
the democrat party has abandoned the
hispanic community they're focused on
white liberals they're not focused on
the hispanic community they can care
less you know and they just are not
representing our values again we're all
about faith and family and hard work and
that's not the democratic party but
what's happening in south texas is a
maida florida's wave i'm fighting for
the conservative values that we were
instilled and i think that it's
important that we continue fighting for
those values and look i'm not loyal to a
party i'll say it over and over my
loyalty is with god and with my family
and what in with my community and i
believe that it's time to put texas
district 34 first we've never had a
voice here in washington no one really
cared what we had to say and now people
do care about the hispanic community now
people actually care about the voice of
texas district 34 and i'm just so proud
and humbled to be representing um all uh
texas district 34 and all hispanic
community throughout the country a lot
of the attention you've been receiving
has also been because your husband is a
border patrol agent and obviously there
is a crisis at our southern border that
has to be dealt with what is the message
you are bringing to washington what is
your perspective and what are you going
to do to solve the problem and make the
situation better at our southern border
well i believe that we need to focus on
legal immigration and improving the
process how we can make it more you know
faster affordable for the good people
that want to come here for the american
dream i'll never understand why the
democrat party wants to encourage
illegal immigration knowing that they're
going to have to go through abuse and
knowing that children are going to be
put into child sex trafficking it's
because of the democrat party right now
we have a serious problem with child sex
trafficking in the united states and we
really care about children because let
me tell you no matter where children are
from they're innocent and we need to
protect children and if we care about
children we would focus on border
security to keep children safe and so
women also wouldn't have to go through
so much abuse let's allow them to come
here to this country legally but let's
improve the process but unfortunately
the democratic party doesn't care that
they're going to have to go through such
abuse
so it's heartbreaking let's look toward
uh november if we could myra because uh
you will be running against vaseta
gonzalez whose current representative
from the 15th congressional district and
is moving over to what will be the newly
uh
installed 34th redrawn congressional
district some folks say that your race
is going to be a little more difficult
in november
it's a lot more difficult for vicente
it's a lot more difficult for vicente he
thought that jumping into texas district
34 was going to be an easier win well
it's not it's going to be the toughest
fight he's ever he's ever fought and
honestly he thinks he's a better
representative because he was born in
texas and i was born in mexico and i
have a message to him that even though i
was born in mexico i love this country
very much and i'm representing texas
district 34 because i love my my
district and i want to see texas
district 34 blossom yeah the the point
that i was i was getting to there was
that the the newly redrawn borders of
the district will be in effect in the
november 8th election but but
republicans seem to be better
at picking viable candidates than they
were in the past when it comes to
latinas and latinos we had uh yes lee
vega
who won the primary in the seventh
congressional district in virginia and
it's expected that she will likely run a
very strong race against abigail
spanberger in november so
is this represent a real investment on
the part of the republican party in
getting good latino and latina
candidates to run in these general
elections in special elections
absolutely we are their best investment
and no matter what the lines are south
texas is very conservative again we are
conservative by nature faith family and
hard work that's not the democrat party
i'm fighting for those values and we
need that type of representation in
washington
um that being said you've gotten a lot
of attention i wonder i wonder how you
feel about all that attention elon musk
and others the first time i ever voted
republican
how does it feel to get all this
attention what do you think it says
about the state of your party
i'm so grateful to him and also spacex
for everything that they're doing for
for south texas and the opportunities
that they're giving to
to the people in texas district 34 it's
because of him that you know thousands
and thousands of jobs were created in
our district and i'm forever grateful to
him and everyone else who who wants to
come to south texas we are the most
hardworking uh people so i invite you
know people to come to south texas and
invest in south texas because we are not
only uh amazing people all about faith
and family but also the most hardworking
uh so just a final question for you here
i just want to give you an opportunity
to address this because some of your
critics have pointed out that a couple
of years ago when you were the
chairwoman for the hispanic outreach
of the republican party for hidalgo
county you put a couple of social media
posts out there that included hashtags
for q and on and i'm just wondering
where you come down in that whole q a
i'll say it over and over it was a
hashtag my post is actually against it
i've never supported any of those uh
conspiracies and none of this nonsense
and again
washington wants us to again washington
wants us to focus on nonsense i'm
focused on the issues that matter in my
district and right now we're focused on
the increase of gas increase of
groceries and the increase of health
care and so many other issues place this
why was it included in the tweets though
it was an account obviously managed by
you why was it even stay focused stay
focused
we are focused on the issues that matter
i think that uh anybody who watches fox
news would tell you that we're just
wondering what you say to the critics
who point to that and we're curious as
to why you would have included those in
the first place
i've said it over and over never
supported none of those conspiracies
again stay focused on the issues that
really matter to to the american people
border crisis and of course the economy
fair enough good to talk to you
congresswoman myra flores from the great
state of texas uh and we'll be seeing
more of you no question about that thank
you so much thank you for joining us all
right absolutely i went to brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now